[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous j'espère
que vous allez bien bienvenue dans cette
émission le 78 nous sommes le jeudi 5
octobre voici le programme de ce soir
octobre rose le mois de sensibilisation
au cancer du sein se poursuit plusieurs
communes des zvelines se mobilise pour
libérer la parole et faire de la
prévention àelle en cours plusieurs
stands été proposés au public pour
mettre la lumière sur cette lumière sur
cette maladie qui touche 1,3 million de
femmes entre 50 et 74 ans à partir de
demain et jusqu'au 16 octobre c'est la
fête de la science pour l'occasion
l'Institut de Radi prototection et de
sûreté nucléaire situé au vziné ouvre
ses portes au public découverte du site
visite ou encore atelier se dérouleront
durant tout le weekend et le jeudi comme
d'habitude nous vous donnerons nos idées
de sortie dans les ivelines au programme
le Festival International du Cirque au
Murau la biénale des beauards de
rambouiller mais aussi la fête du miel à
plaisir les détails avec notre
journaliste Gabriel Gontier et puis les
invités du 78 en 2e partie d'émission
l'observatoire de Versailles
SaintQuentin en Yveline et l'UFR Simone
veille santé vous invit dans leur
laboratoire pour fêter la science et on
en parlera justement avec Marianne
bertera bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes
chargé de communication pour
l'observatoire de Versailles
Saint-Quentin en yeline un site qui
regroupe quatre laboratoires à
l'occasion de la Fête de la Science vous
ouvrirez vos portes au public le
dimanche 15 octobre à vos côtés Aurélie
goyenval bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
chercheuse à l'UFR Simon veille santé le
programme est également très riche de
votre côté puisque l'UFR ouvrira ses
portes le samedi 14 octobre on en
parlera en fin d'émission avec nous
également sur ce plateau une journaliste
de la rédaction action de tv78 Gabrielle
Gontier bonsoir bonsoir math vous allez
nous présenter vos idées de sortie dans
quelques instants mais avant on va faire
un point avec vous sur les informations
à retenir aujourd'hui dans le
département et on commence ces
informations Gabriel par une nouvelle
pour les communes qui ont été touchées
par les émeutes de juillet dernier oui
Mathilde et le gouvernement veut clore
cette séquence Matignon a annoncé que
ellisabeth born présentera à la fin du
mois les réponses au Mair des villes les
plus touchées par les émeutes 500 édiles
seront conviés à noter qu'aujourd'hui un
conseil national de la refondation
consacré à ce sujet a été présidé en fin
de journée par la première ministre en
présence d'une cinquantaine de
personnalités parmi eux un ivelinoir à
fael cogier merire de Montel jolie à
guillancour le maire François Morton a
annoncé une prime exceptionnelle pour
ses agents oui une prime allant de 300 à
800 € bruts selon la rémunération des
agents les raisons évoqué le pouvoir
d'achat dans un communiqué François
Morton annonce que 600 agents municipaux
sont concernés ce dont la rémunération
mensuelle brute ne dépasse pas les 3250
€ brut montant global 410000 € la prime
a été votée à l'unanimité le 3 octobre
dernier à l'occasion du dernier conseil
municipal et on termine ces informations
Gabriel par un rally oui un rally celui
des classes défens ce jeudi au Camp des
Loges de Saint-Germain en lait CQ
classes ont fait leur rally d'entrée par
rally comprenait un moment d'échange
entre militaire et élèves cinq classes
dont quatre de Saint-Germain en lait ont
pu découvrir les soldats de l'opération
sentinelle les différents métiers qui
composent l'armée ou encore assister à
une démonstration cyophile ce projet
pédagogique concerne des classes de
collèges et de lycée paréné par une
unité militaire pour faire le lien armée
jeunesse les militaires sont amenés à
faire des échanges au sein même des
classes et les élèves à participer à des
cérémonies et bien merci beaucoup
Gabriel Gontier pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une image ou une
information qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag set
news un mois pour sensibiliser et
prévenir le cancer du sein c'est
l'objectif d'Octobre Rose plusieurs
stands d'informations et de dépistage
été proposé au public hier mercredi 4
octobre à Lagora dlencour c'est le
reportage de Julien Leroi intérêt pour
participer au dépistage organisé c'est
la double lecture de votre mamographie
par de Radi différents d'accord libérer
la parole face au cancer du sein une
journée de sensibilisation était
organisé ce mercredi 4 octobre au Centre
Social Lagora d'éancour échange sur la
prévention ou l'accompagnement une
nécessité de dialogue face à un constat
en France 1,3 million de femmes entre 50
et 74 ans n'ont jamais participé à un
dépistage contre cette maladie on a
beaucoup de femmes qui ont une
méconnaissance des modalités de
participation au dépistage du cancer du
du sein on a beaucoup de femmes aussi
qui ne pensent pas à prendre le temps de
s'occuper d'elle si un cancer est
détecté
précocement cela va permettre à 99
femmes sur 100 de pouvoir survivre dans
les 5 ans des50e anniversaire chacune
reçoit à son domicile un courrier
l'invitant à prendre rendez-vous pour un
examen auprès d'un radiologue en amont
l'autoexamen Mamère régulier est
recommandé à partir de 25 ans avec des
observations spécifiques un volume de
qui peut augmenter ou alors qui change
de forme un mamelon qui va se rétracter
une une indenduration ou alors tout
simplement un une rougeur sur le sein
une peau d'orange et ensuite de passer
au toucher c'est-à-dire de pouvoir bah
tout simplement toucher ses seins aussi
largement possible pour que tout
simplement on puisse sentir des choses
qui ne seraient pas habituelles durant
ce mois de prévention octobre rose de
nombreux événements seront proposés à
hlencour prochain rendez-vous ce weekend
avec des activités familiales pour sout
tenir la lutte contre le cancer le plus
fréquent chez la femme et d'autres
événements ont lieu ce weekend dans les
yvelin n'hésitez pas à vous renseigner
sur le site Internet de votre commune
pour avoir plus d'informations ce
weekend c'est également la fête de la
science à cette occasion l'Institut de
radio protection et de sûreté nucléaire
situé au visiné ouvre ses portes au
public les visiteurs pourront ainsi se
mettre dans la dans la peau d'un
scientifique le reportage de Clara de
Frutos et Julien
ro fans de science les chercheurs de
l'IRSN du visinet ouvrent les portes de
leur laboratoire tout le weekend pour la
2e année consécutive au programme
découverte du site visite et atelier
autour du thème de la radioactivité étap
pour cet échantillon dans le cadre des
fêtes de la science àiracen on souhaite
expliquer notre activité pour la
population du vaisiné pour nos nouveaux
voisins l'écoquartier de la princesse ce
que nous avons préparé est adapté pour
un public de 7 à 77 ans il y aura des
conférences thématiques il y aura des
ateliers pédagogiques vous pourrez
visiter nos laboratoire notamment ce
nouveau bâtiment chaque année les
scientifiques prélèvent plus de 6000
échantillons pour mesurer leur
radioactivité eau végétaux sédiments ou
encore aliments grâce à cette nouvelle
plateforme de haute technologie
d'analyse les scientifiques peuvent
analyser plus de 150 échantillons par
jour une faculté unique l'IRSN c'est
l'expert public qui est en charge de la
recherche et de l'expertise dans le
domaine de la matière radiologique et de
tout ce qui est risque nucléaire ça veut
dire que l'IRSN fait notamment l'analyse
des dossiers que peuvent déposer des
exploitants pour démarrer une
installation nucléaire pour faire une
extension ou pour tout ce qui concerne
la vie des installations nucléaires mais
l'Institut a également pour mission de
surveiller l'environnement et ce depuis
que l'industrie du nucléaire existe et
ensuite ça veut dire deux choses ça veut
dire étudier et voir l'influence des
installations nucléaires sur
l'environnement dans leur dans le cadre
de leur fonctionnement normal comme
toute industrie une installation
nucléaire conduit à des rejets dans
l'environnement qui est réglementé qui
sont autorisé mais on a aussi une
mission de surveillance de l'ensemble du
territoire et on vérifie que les niveaux
sont finalement aux quantités attendues
gratuit et ouvert à tous sans
inscription c'est l'occasion unique de
découvrir ce site
historique allez c'est l'heure à présent
de passer à notre page
[Musique]
loisir graveur céramiste ou encore
musicien 80 artistes de la Vallée de
Chevreuse présentent leur œuvre au
public durant l'événement parcours
d'Artist et l'un d'entre eux Patrick
Pogu aquarelliste nous a ouvert les
portes de son atelier am mani lesam
c'est le reportage de Julien Leroi
bienvenue à tv78 je vais vous faire
visiter mon atelier c'est par là une
invitation à les merveillement Patrick
Pogu peintre autodidacte de 77 ans est
originaire de maniamau dès le début de
sa retraite il y a une quinzaine
d'années il se passionne pour cet art
avec une appétence particulière pour
l'aquarelle dessin choix des couleurs ou
des harmonies cette technique de
peinture à l'eau sur papier nécessite un
grand travail préparatoire ce qui
m'intéresse le plus dans l'aquarelle
c'est l'inattendu c'est-à-dire que on
part dans l'aquarelle dans le mouiller
c'est-à-dire je je mouille totalement ma
feuille et je pose des pigment on arrive
à avoir des effets tout à fait
inattendus qui sont les plus beaux
effets du tableau qu'on a prévu de faire
portrait architecture ou paysage Patrick
Pogu fait découvrir au curieux son
travail dans l'atelier de sa maison une
mise en lumière durant les deux premiers
weekends d'octobre pour l'événement
parcours d'artiste organisé par
l'association héium moi j'ai toujours un
peu de mal à à savoir si ce qui me plaît
va plaire au public donc là je je je
vois la réaction du public je discute
avec eux et c'est des moments qui sont
qui sont super environ 80 participants
originaires de la vallée de chevreus
collaborent à ce 19e parcours d'artiste
plasticien sculpteur ou photographe ce
voyage artistique se poursuivra le
weekend
prochain et on poursuit cette page
loisir avec vos idées de sortie pour ce
weekend dans les ivelines Gabriel et on
commence avec un événement international
qui revient au Mureaux oui le Festival
International du Cirque des Mureaux est
de retour Mathilde vous l'avez dit il
revient pour une 21e édition début des
festivités vendredi jusqu'à dimanche
alors comme chaque année les meilleurs
artistes du monde se sont donné un
rendez-vous pour fouler la piste du
célèbre cirque au programme du weekend
sangle aérienne roue la mort ou encore
funambulisme à la présentation l'artiste
anglaise carry Hervé cette année encore
un prix récompensera le plus beau numéro
du festival vous nous proposer un autre
rendez-vous Gabriel un peu moins
périlleux c'est à Montini le Bretonneux
oui cette fois pas de roue de la mort ou
d'acrobatie mais le retour du salon
international d'art contemporain arm
Manet ce weekend qui s'installe à la
Ferme du Manet une quarantaine
d'artistes ont été sélectionnés cette
année parmi eux essentiellement des
peintres mais aussi des sculpteurs et
des photographes locaux et
internationaux dans sa volonté de rendre
l'art accessible à tous cette année
encore l'entrée est gratuite j'ai
rencontré le commissaire général de
l'exposition Philippe bastonni l'entrée
est libre effectivement on souhaite que
tout le monde les adultes les enfants
que tout le monde puisse profiter
l'intérêt de notre manifestation c'est
que au-delà des œuvres que l'on peut
voir on peut rencontrer les artistes
discuter avec les artistes et eux-mêmes
sont très demandeur d'échange avec le
public bon de l'art et du partage vous
avez compris et le salon soutient
également la lutte contre Alzheimer les
bénéfices de cette édition seront
reversés à cette cause et du côté de
Rambouillet c'est la bienénale desb qui
fait son retour oui dès samedi et
jusqu'au 22 octobre le rendez-vous
rambolittin des amoureux des beauards
revient pour cette 4e édition 113
artistes ont été choisis par le comité
de sélection et près de 190 œuvres pour
l'ouverture de cet événement un jury
décernera un prix au lauréat du salon un
rendez-vous à ne pas rater car
l'exposition se tient seulement tous les
2 ans et je crois qu'il y a un autre
rendez-vous à noter pour ceux qui sont
plus adeptes bah de la nourriture des
produits locaux exactement et lesabelle
qui seront à l'honneur ce weekend pour
la 30e édition de la Fête du miel de
nombreuses activités sont prévues pour
les familles extraction de miel
confection de bougie ou encore
observation des ruches vous pourrez bien
sûr Mathilde goûter au miel
d'huile-de-fance et bien d'autres
spécialités local au total c'est une
vingtaine d'exposants qui proposeront
leurs produits pardon alors rendez-vous
ce weekend et ça se passe au château de
plaisir et pourquoi pas aussi profiter
du weekend avec un peu d'histoire c'est
ce que propose le château de versaill
oui à l'occasion du 250e anniversaire de
la naissance de LouisPhilippe le château
de Versailles organise une programmation
spéciale tout le weekend dernier roi de
France et initiateur de la création du
musée du château inauguré en 1837 vous
pourrez découvrir les œuvres les plus
emblématiques comme la salle consacrée
au musée de Louis-Philippe dans la
galerie de l'histoire la galerie des
Batailles ou encore les salles
consacrées à l'Empire au-delà du pouvoir
la vie intime du monarque aussi est
représenté avec l'ouverture de ces
salons privés du Grand Triano et bien
merci beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour
toutes ces idées de sortie est-ce que
vous aimez jouer au jeux de société
c'est toujours sympa entre amis c'est
c'est sympa l'hiver c'est ça exactement
plus
l'hiver alors je vous pose cette
question parce que la semaine dernière
s'est tenu le premier festival yvelinois
de jeux de société vous y étiez Gabriel
pour tourner le reportage qui va suivre
c'était l'occasion pour les familles et
les amis de se réunir pour un pour
partager un moment convivial et donc
c'est le reportage de Gabri ger et deis
Douch c'eston
pour on
distribes
jou jeux classique plus moderne et
familiaux l'association entre quatre
jeux a lancé son premier festival dédié
au jeux de société à SaintQuentin en
Yvel l'objectif rassembler des joueurs
de tous les âges autour d'une même
passion on est heureux de passer ce
moment ensemble et c'est que du bonheur
c'est bien organisé quand on voit la
variété de je il y a ça il y a forcément
un jeu pour chaque enfant et c'est un
plaisir un large choix de jeux réparti
sur une vingtaine de tables quels que
soient les goûts et compétences les
joueurs occasionnels ou confirmés
pouvaient trouver leur bonheur mais ça
ça compte un jeeton il fa en rendre ah
oui c'est l'occasion de découvrir des
nouveaux jeux on en a pas mal à la
maison plein les placards mais il y en a
encore à découvrir ça peut donner des
idées de cadeaux Noël approche à grand
pas finalement et là c'est bien possible
que ça finisse sur la liste du Père Noël
le Marvel cette année
l'occasion également de rencontrer
auteurs et auditeurs de jeux de société
pour échanger avec eux découvrir les
coulisses de la création de ces jeux
parfois nés au cœur des ivelines on a
beau en tant que créateur avoir toutes
les idées qu'on veut à la
fin la réalité c'est le contact avec le
public on est une association locale en
crrée dans une dans un environnement
local aussi et donc c'est créateur de
jeux local on les on les côtoie ils
viennent à l'association on les voit un
petit peu tout le temps donc c'était un
les mettre en avant aussi aujourd'hui
avec 350 personnes présentes la première
édition de ce festival a été un succès
l'association prévoit déjà une seconde
édition l'année
prochaine je vous propose à présent de
faire un bon dans le passé le weekend
dernier 5 associations ont revêtu leur
habit d'époque pour des reconstitutions
militaires grandeur nature au château de
Breteuil un voyage inédit au cœur de
l'histoire c'est le reportage de Gabriel
Gontier
la montée des couleurs comme si vous y
étiez au côté du 26e régiment
d'infanterie de l'armée
américaine le temps d'un weekend les
jardins du château de Breteuil à Choisel
se sont transformés en camp militaire
proposant de véritables scènes de vie et
de démonstration aux visiteurs nous
avons décidé de présenter ben des choses
un petit peu euh qui sortent de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler d'habitude le côté
guerrier de la reconstitution historique
donc vous allez voir notamment bon bien
entendu des armes des choses comme ça
mais des choses un petit peu plus euh
différentes à savoir ce qu'on appelle un
displ cuisine un poste de commandement
une tente pour les les soldats ainsi que
le
Dallas unique en France vu que nous
sommes les seuls à en avoir un des
pièces uniques et de toutes les époques
des soldats de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale en remontant par les poilus de
1418 ou encore la garde de
napoléonienne au-delà du folklore ce qui
anime ses passionnés c'est avant tout la
sauvegarde du patrimoine et le devoir de
mémoire nous avons pour but de faire de
l'histoire vivante et de recréer la vie
journalière du des grenadiers à pied de
la Garde impériale sous Napoléon prier
apprêtez vos armes au bleu
joue
pe mais avant d'intégrer la garde
passage obligatoire par le recrutement
alors demain matin est-ce que tu peux
être là à 6h au garde à vous de vos
battentes des reconstitutions qui
fascinent et inspirent aussi bien les
petits que les grand c'est bien de
garder le le souvenir de tout ça et
c'est bien qu'il a des gens qui qui se
déguise comme ça je suis passionné
militariage quand je serai un peu plus
grand je commencé à faire de la
reconstitution dans le civil et quand je
serai plus grand dans le militaire arme
à l'épaule droite droite un bond dans
l'histoire qui créera peut-être quelques
vocations et c'est bientôt l'heure de
passer aux invités du 78 mais juste
avant je vous je vous propose de jeter
un coup d'œil à la météo de
demain
demain matin nous devrions avoir un beau
ciel bleu dans les ivelines il sera
juste légèrement voiler du côté de
Mantel jolie et de Versailles au niveau
des températures ça se rafraîchit le
matin il fera 8 à Houdan 9 à
mantelajolie et rambouillé et 10 à
versaill demain après-midi il y aura un
grand soleil sur tout le département et
côté température il fera 21° en moyenne
pour les prévisions météo de ce weekend
le soleil sera toujours de la partie
samedi il fera environ 9°gr le matin et
22° l'après-midi et dimanche le soleil
continuera de briller sur les ivelines
avec des températures le matin à 10°r
environ et l'après-midi ça va se
réchauffer avec des moyennes à 25° c'est
l'heure à présent de passer aux invités
du
[Musique]
78 la Fête de la Science commence demain
et se tiendra jusqu'au 16 octobre en
France à cette occasion plusieurs
animations sont prévues à l'université
de Versailles Saint-Quentin en Yveline
pour en parler avec nous Marianne
bertera chargée de communication pour
l'observatoire de Versailles
Saint-Quentin en Yveline et Aurélie
goyenval chercheuse à l'UFR Simone
veille santé alors Marienne bertera la
Fête de la Science ça commence mercredi
prochain à l'ovasq pour pour les élèves
pour les groupes scolaires vous allez
proposer plusieurs ateliers notamment
sur la météo ou les nanosatellites ou
encore même le réchauffement climatique
tout à fait est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire un peu plus tout à fait on
attend un petit peu moins de 1000 élèves
du tout le du territoire 78 donc
beaucoup d'élèves quand même beaucoup
d'élèves du CM1 à la
terminale peu importe le
l'orientation peu importe les
spécificités en fait des cours voilà on
a des gens qui viennent qui sont dédiés
à l'ingénierie mais d'autres qui sont
plus dédiés à l'hôtellerie donc c'est
une une perspective et un souhait de
vouloir ouvrir des des portes qu'on n'
pas l'habitude d'ouvrir en fait voilà
d'ù le fait de la faê de la science sert
à ça et ça permet aussi de susciter des
des vocations des vocations chez les
plus jeunes on aimerait bien ou oui bien
sûr c'est aussi euh ce que vous
constatez Aurélie goyenval vous en tant
que chercheuse il y a des enfants des
élèves qui viennent vous voir et qui
vous demandent c'est quoi le métier de
chercheuse qu'est-ce que vous faites au
quotidien oui tout à fait c'est vraiment
une des raisons qui nous pousse à à
ouvrir nos portes de de laboratoire
c'est ça fait partie des missions qu'on
a c'est aussi de créer des vocations
donc nous on aime quand même partager
effectivement bah notre passion parce
que c'est quand même des métiers
passions les métiers de de chercheur et
donc là à travers tous ces ateliers
effectivement on espère créer des
vocations il y a pas mal de jeunes déjà
l'année dernière qui voilà qui venaient
nous voir et qui étaient assez ébahi de
voir enfin des microscopes toutes ces
voilà on peut passer de l'extrêmement
grand à à l' SQ à l'extrêmement petit
chez nous donc c'est très varié et alors
à l'UFR Simone veille santé la fête de
la science c'est samedi 14 octobre et
vous organisez notamment bah un escape
game tout à fait donc on a deux escape
GAM on a un escape game immersif donc
vraiment classique on va dire et donc
les où les les personnes sont enfermées
dans un laboratoire et Don ont donc 20
minutes pour sortir et doivent voilà
déchiffrer des petits codes sur
scientifique pour pouvoir sortir et il y
a un escape game numérique donc là
vraiment c'est pour insister sur les
nouvelles technologies du pôle
pédagogique donc c'est ces deux aspects
numériques et immersifs qui peuvent
plaire aux plus jeunes et aux familles
on l'espère donc ça a été un vrai succès
l'année dernière donc on espère que ce
le sera cette année aussi oui le but de
l'événement c'est ça aussi c'est de
déconstruire un peu les clichés de la
science très intellectuel très carré là
c'est c'est une fête en fait
complètement c'est une fête c'est c'est
vraiment des ateliers toute qui sont
ludiques qu'on veut que on veut que ce
soit familial hein donc c'est vraiment
c'est le but c'est que c'est vraiment
que ce soit familial et ludique et donc
on essaie effectivement de déconstruire
cette image du chercheur un peu
poussiéreux ce qui est pas du tout le
cas j'espère voilà qu'on qu'on aura de
nombreux participants pour pouvoir
ensuite transmettre cette information
c'est plutôt un événement familial les
gens viennent en famille pour montrer à
leurs enfants exactement donc c'est
vraiment alors nous on l'ouvre à partir
de de de 10 ans euh après il peut y
avoir des un peu plus jeunes pour
certains ateliers ça dépend des ateliers
euh mais effectivement le but c'est
vraiment d'être en famille que voilà
c'est parce que c'est passionnant pour
les grands aussi donc c'est il a il y a
un peu tout tous les types d'activités à
faire il y a une et donc il y aura aussi
un atelier de avec des casques de
réalité virtuelles exactement donc ça
aussi ça plaît beaucoup aux jeune et
donc il y a c'est effectivement un
atelier de de réalité virtuelle pour
montrer comment on peut utiliser la la
réalité virtuelle dans la médecine
aujourd'hui et donc cet atelier plonge
vraiment le le participant face à un
patient et comment éventuellement
décider de prescrire ou pas de la
morphine à un patient donc vraiment
c'est très imersif et donc ça aussi ça
plaît beaucoup aux jeunes en général
donc c'était un grand succès aussi et
alors le dimanche 15 octobre c'est
l'OVSQ qui prend le relais Marianne
bertera quel est quel est le programme
de cette journée il y aura une dizaine
d'ateliers euh on pourra aussi être
enfermé mais dans un planétarium pour le
coup voilà pour aller essayer de
comprendre un petit peu de quoi est fait
le ciel observer les étoil voil
complètement il y aura aussi un atelier
carte du ciel pour apprendre à décrypter
ce qu'on voit à travers la fenêtre de sa
chambre par exemple essayer de repérer
les constellations mars voà les planètes
du système solaire également un atelier
sur le CO2 pourquoi on parle autant de
CO2 dans le réchauffement en quoi ça
consiste comment on peut le capter
comment il il se familiarise autour de
nous ENF comment le on peut le le voir
euh voilà donc là encore le gros du
programme c'est de vulgariser la science
complètement on adapte tout tout enfin
ce sont des gens qui ont l'habitude hein
ça fait partie aussi de leur vocation
c'est on ils parlent entre eux mais ils
parlent aussi aux citoyens enfin c'est
aussi ça le but c'est de faire passer
des messages donc s'ils adaptent pas
leur manière de parler et donc de en
vulgarisant il y a pas vraiment
d'intérêt donc et je crois qu'il sera
aussi possible de construire son propre
vaisseau spatial oui tout à fait c'est
possible c'est possible ça peut
intéresser ça peut intéresser
complètement alors c'est sous forme de
jeu donc c'est digital voilà mais le but
c'est d'essayer de réussir à faire
décoller la fusée donc par plusieurs
tentatives et plusieurs essais la
puissance qu'on va mettre comment on
équipe le vaisseau et voir si on arrive
à atteindre l'objectif alors est-ce que
à l'OVSQ ou à l'UFR Simone veille santé
il y aura des lieux qui seront
exceptionnellement ouverts au public ce
ces deux journées oui alors bah
effectivement on ouvre les laboratoires
donc nous il y a une des activités qui
est une activité de visite notamment des
des plateformes technologiques où
vraiment on peut voir les tout dernier
microscope donc là il y a vraiment un
accès unique heinon on a jamais de porte
ouvertte de de la sorte donc c'est
vraiment une opportunité à saisir j'ai
envie de dire parce que c'est c'est
super intéressant de pouvoir voir
effectivement toutes les activités de
recherche on essaie de représenter le
panel des activités de recherche qui a
lieu à l'UFR Simone veille santé qui est
assez large hein parce qu'on va de
l'école des sages-femmes jusqu'à de
l'anthropologie donc il y a vraiment un
un un panel assez varié qu'on a essayé
de représenter à travers toute tous ces
ateliers toutes ces activités et à
l'OVSQ est-ce qu'il y aura des lieux
exceptionnellement ouverts au publicque
on aura la plateforme d'intégration et
de test qui est un lieu qui nous permet
de tester par exemple il y a un
anosatellite qui est parti avec les
étudiants de l'université et donc ils
sont testés en fait dans des cuves à
vies par exemple pour pouvoir
simuler le le vide de l'espace en fait
et voir comment les appareils réagissent
avant en voie et bien merci beaucoup
Marianne bertera et Aurélie goyenval
d'avoir répondu à nos questions et
d'avoir accepté notre invitation en
plateau alors si vous êtes intéressé la
fête de la science à l'UFR Simone veille
santé c'est samedi 14 octobre de 9h à
18h et à l'OVSQ c'est le dimanche 15
octobre de 10h à 18h et c'est la fin de
ce 78 merci pour votre fidélité je vous
souhaite une belle soirée sur tv78 et un
bon weekend prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous